one of the things
i'd love to get your thoughts on this is
uh antiviral
ideas so ideas outside of the vaccine
so ivermectin
something that uh brett weinstein and a
few others have been talking about
there's been a few studies some of them
have been shown not to be very good
studies
but nevertheless
there seems to be some promise
and
i wanted to talk to brett
uh about this particular topic for two
reasons one i was really bothered by
censorship of this that's a whole other
topic
i i just
i'm bothered by sensors there's a gray
area of course
um
but
i it just feels like that should not
have been censored from youtube like
discussions of vivomectin we can we can
set that aside
the the other thing i was bothered by
the lack of open-mindedness mindedness
on exploring things like avermectin
in the early days
especially when at least i thought the
vaccine would take a long time
i mean it's not just ivamectin it's
really
seriously at a large scale rigorously
exploring the effectiveness of masks
and the big one for me is testing
like the fact that that wasn't explored
aggressively
to lead to mass manufacturing like may
2020 is as absurd
anyway
uh so i was bothered by these solutions
not being explored and not by now having
really good ivermectin studies so can i
talk about ivory mechanics yeah i would
love that yeah sure so full disclosure
my wife
worked on ivermectin at merc for 20
years
okay
so
i just want people to know but i didn't
i
don't talk to her all the time about it
anyway she hasn't been at merc for a
long time as you know ivermectin is a
very safe drug used to treat certain
parasitic infections yes right
and
it is approved it's amazing you can take
one dose a year and be protected against
river blindness in africa and certain
parts of africa it's remarkably
effective
and so
it's quite a safe drug at the doses that
are
that are approved
now
early last year a study was done i
believe in australia which showed in
cells in the lab if you infect with
source cov2 and and put ivermectin in it
would inhibit the virus production
substantially it was quite clear right
but the concentrations they were using
were rather high and
could not be achieved by
the the
approved dosing so you would need to do
a dosing study to make sure it's safe
and the reason is that i have a mechanic
binds to receptors in your brain and it
can have high doses a lot of some people
take high doses
inappropriately and they have
neurological consequences so
if you needed 10 times more ivermectin
you'd have to make sure it would be safe
in people so this is a question of
safety too right so
my i think it has always been the case
that it should have been properly
studied
but it wasn't there are lots of trials
here and there lots of improperly
controlled trials where someone would
just treat some patients and say hey
they all did fine but have no control
arm and there were some controlled
trials but they were very small so right
now
a four thousand person trial is unroll
enrolling to test and at randomly
controlled trial
setting
whether it works or not there's still
plenty of cases that you can do that so
you can ask whether in there whether
there are any side effects i think
that's completely fine and if it says
it works then we should use it in the
meantime
i always tell people
if you want to use ivermectin you can do
it off label it's fda approved and if
your physician says i'm going to give
you this off label
i don't have a
any objection but i don't know if it's
going to work now
a friend of ours
last week in new jersey got
covered he went to his local hospital
and their regimen was rem deservier
dexamethasone
ivermectin it's written that's what they
do for every covent patient they just
give it to them automatically and um
wow so he's he recovered so
who's to say it was or were not was not
ivermectin right so i don't have any
strong ideological opposition i just
think it should be tested for what you
want to use it for yeah and that's being
done and i think that's fine is it
strange to you that um
ivermectin or other things like it
weren't tested aggressively in the
beginning like
from a broad
scientific
community
aspect
you know i can be a little bit
conspiratorial and this is what people
talk about with evamectin yeah is with
the vaccines there's quite a lot of
money to be made
with avermectin there's not as much
money to be made
is is that too conspiratorial like why
didn't we try more solutions in the
beginning
well um well all the money was put into
vaccines right very little was put into
antivirus because the decision was made
at a very high level probably involving
dr fauci yeah we're going to put 24
billion into vaccines right yeah
and i think part of the reasoning is
they give you years worth of protection
whereas an antiviral works and you have
to keep dosing and so forth but
ivermectin is not trivial in this i
agree it should have been tested early
on but we had a really bad experience
with hydroxychloroquine which we can
right talk about too um
ivermectin is very hard to synthesize
most
drugs you synthesize chemically you
devise a formulation in a synthesis and
they do it they scale it up and it's
fine avermectin's really hard and so
what they do instead
is they take the culture of the
bacterium that makes it and they grow it
up and they ferment it and then they
purify it
and merck owns the bacteria
a number of years ago two employees of
merck stole it and left the company
and tried to market and they were
arrested and they got put in jail so
they protect it very carefully
so
you can't just make it
if you do it's incredibly expensive and
now india it's very cheap apparently
they use it uh quite liberally there and
i don't know how they're they're making
it maybe they've licensed it from merck
and so forth but
that's why it hasn't been tested more
widely i think there's complexities in
terms of getting a lot of it and
manufacturing a lot of it yes okay so
what was the other the hydrogen
hydroxychloroquine was also shown
early on to inhibit virus in cell
culture
and that's not surprising
hydroxychloroquine of course
is used for malaria
and what it does
when you're when your cell takes up
things from the from the plasma membrane
including viruses it goes through a
pathway called the endocytic pathway
which involves a vesicle moving through
the cell and as it moves through the
cell its ph drops
and that lets a lot of viruses out
actually and hydroxychloroquine blocks
that so it blocks infection with a lot
of viruses
so the problem with those early studies
that were published
is that they were done in kidney cells
in culture
where the only way the virus can get in
is through the endosome
and hydroxychloroquine inhibits that and
that's why it inhibits
in kidney cells and culture but lung
cells
and respiratory cells of humans where
the virus reproduces
can get in two different ways it can get
in from this endocytic pathway
which is inhibited by hydroxychloroquine
or it can get in at the cell surface
which is not inhibited by
hydroxychloroquine so when you treat
patients
it has no effect in the lung because
the virus can just bypass it
and all the
usage initially were based on
the studies done in kidney cells and
culture so that that was just wrong
scientifically incorrect yet it drove a
lot of and today many people still think
they should be taking it but so like the
that not panning out kind of resulted in
a
loss of optimism about other similar
things
well that and many other drugs repurpose
drugs were tried right a lot of hiv
antivirals were tried i think the
problem with hydrox i think hydroxycork
would influence the ivermectin narrative
right people thought that
the data was being hidden about
hydroxychloroquine so they said well
they must be doing the same thing with
hydromaxim but with hydroxychloroquine
it just scientifically could not work
as an antiviral
the other problem that is more broad
that is important to point out is that
when you
when you have covet and you need an
antivirus usually because you can't
breathe and you go in a hospital
because if you're mildly ill you're
never going to go to your doctor and ask
for an antiviral and the problem is when
you can't breathe it's no longer a viral
issue it is now an inflammatory issue
and no antiviral in the world is going
to help you so if that's why rem
deserver doesn't work very well because
it's mainly given intravenously to
people who go in a hospital
if you get ivermectin in the hospital
it's not going to do anything for for
reducing virus because by that time you
have very little virus to begin with you
have an inflammatory problem that you
need to treat in other ways so
this is
why a lot of the antivirals failed
because so use too late what you need is
a pill you take on that first positive
test when you have a scratchy throat
you get a pcr in 15 minutes i'm positive
take a pill boom that's going to inhibit
it if you wait till you can't breathe
and that's why the monoclonals even
don't work if if you're in hospital that
well because it's too late and that the
approach now is if you're in a high risk
group if you're over 65
if you are obese or have diabetes or any
other comorbidities your first sign of a
scratchy throat positive you get
monoclonals
then they might help you but if you wait
till you go in a hospital it's too late
because the viral curve
drops after that first symptom
within three days you're you're no
longer shedding enough virus to transmit
drops really quickly so that's the
reason a lot of these antivirals failed
because they were tested in hospitalized
patients
and we have nothing but rem deserve here
now unfortunately so it was the wrong
approach we should have
been
giving it to people who just tested
positive from the start or just even for
preventative let's see you could do that
too yeah but i have to say the other
issue is
this mole nuperovir is a drug in phase
three now it's an oral antiviral it
looks good
if we go ahead with just one
we're going to get resistance within a
few months and it will be useless we
need to have at least two or three drugs
that we can give in combinations and we
know that because that's what took care
of hiv that's what took care of hcv
hepatitis c virus it really reduces the
emergence of resistance
you